we're so cute it's time for some chicken
Oh her Oliver character dad I don't know
what this game is oh jeez
oh gosh go up its board computer putting
a penis uh oppress why yeah you could
pick up are we helping each other are we
like trying to stop no you want to be
the only one to win
however do you guys see the box with a
question mark yeah we want to we do want
to work together to get that set unlocks
new stuff that we can use next time what
is that Bob is that a door no what is
that you guys are so dumb yeah God oh
no stupid oh you didn't have to die
there you can actually jump up the wall
why did it be with us let him lay I mean
die let him die damn it
okay we're wait is better than oh I only
won one round
oh my god oh wow ha ha ha ha ha ha
what's that blow up wait I'm not even on
the thing anymore what happened I don't
know
oh god boom Oh cuz you go up in the
making I don't because the bomb destroys
things cuz you like it destroys properly
place oh god oh god oh yeah I found a
way around
uh-uh all right we're gonna have to fix
that I don't know how how do we
fix any of this
put this spray dad are you gonna destroy
the thing I just played okay good you
know oh oh oh I get I get what the bomb
do yeah all right look Oh God Oh
so if I touch those fan blades get that
God knew what he was doing I'm super
unclear yeah the word is crap guys I've
got the advantage for one round
Oh give me this your trout cook
you promised I don't know what half of
these things do yeah you want to search
it way what do we do god no Bob
Bob just teleported yay I did it well
now we're all gonna wings and nobody
gets any points ha ha oh boy
I didn't realize that what's going to
happen oh that is happen yeah
Wade you seem to assume that we know the
who's here
oh uh hey guys there's rules here buddy
wait what's that pig how do I look at
something mark right and left buffer is
what it is you Bob oh okay Zack did
you weights get it okay well lately one
one I know you're me over ain't
this uh there's a thing so so waiting
okay I guess I brought down here well
hey there's a way now you made it to her
I'm just dance I died I should myself
uh it's seppuku I don't um I think
that's possible anymore no no I'm just
gonna guess Jack I'll show you something
mark what huh
what do you did what made this happen
what is happening what is happening oh
gosh I hold B to give up okay my god no
points well it's good to hasn't won yet
okay um pressing the white button brings
up my pause screen okay there we go
your rice thank God oh come on
oh it's gonna be too easy now
I got the solution just wait
I'm smarter than all of you
yeah yeah I almost did the thing I
almost didn't do it my failed
measurement Wow
okay rec rec rec rec rec rec rec what is
that what is that what is that that is
like a lock that's a barrel
I saw believe this is a comput rule you
hear your characters just looking at it
like what the is that what is this
oh ah thank you for a very narrow window
of success why'd you do this oh yes yes
yeah kill ball god my dead body I didn't
know you were dead I was like not very
dead very dead yep very dead yes no not
last
sure I'm on my own demise the crew is
the ultimate chicken you came last last
that's okay
cuz I wanted it I meant to be bad
anytime I'm bad that meant God John wise
are always someone like you that I play
with Bob it has to be ultimate jerk of
the period end of the round I'm a
chicken horse deal with it
oh there's did you there's multiple
pages of traps I didn't see that
oh all blades Oh awesome
yes oh that's so cool wait wait wait
somebody somebody has to give us a pass
where you can spray Oh Wally character
can't move
yes great trigger oh don't tell us how
to play Jack how you doing the game of
my kind oh no Jack try using WASD no
okay all lines just a little bit too
bored still we may have to restart again
dammit are you holding I ended game oh
wait can you move now I ended gay oh
wait so let's not deep disconnect
everyone cuz that yeah Jack said
you can rejoin AK and rejoin he's back
to the rooftops
yay
Hot Springs is now if way in the news
I'm blaming mousing I wasn't ready
maybe hey I didn't need sprint I was
good enough without it even though I got
last place whatever shut your be now oh
my god the mouse doesn't work wait
well I like to look at that more gosh
how about a little bit of that action
alright about a little bit of good luck
try to make this trail I don't need luck
I got lots of skill Bob no Bob Bob I'm
pretty sure you can make that yeah -
come away wait is still she Wow
yeah oh how the bloody bandage for one
round a this game does not work right it
works fine don't criticize it it'll get
me whine and then it won't leave it over
there I don't know what I'm
talking about
god damn it soggy wait we can't win Oh
Danny wait
look guys whoa what is my sciency stuff
what is this
yeah mark out with you lots of this lots
of no no guys those things are so
overpowered why all right well I decided
a town they just suck you in and kill
you instantly gonna put them
look about his parents fair transyl full
it's rare it's fair sprint honey home
rings oh my goodness Bob you said the
butter button please do what you said
the bumper right right trigger X all the
triggers you said bumper wait guys
I'll make it possible don't worry okay
Bob it's gonna be my shadow
you just have to what it does really
good games guys you just don't give me a
chance
yeah sweetie is winning
I'm with why why can't that happen guys
wife why is that not allowed what is
this
I got I got some ideas I got some ideas
don't you worry what even is that oh I
hate this game I don't know what this do
okay oh god where's the balls
that's barbed wire it's gotta go Obama
damn it whatever I wanna keep while is
below it well you saw I don't know what
these is Oh
do I got idea why is there a random
teleporter floating in the middle of the
sky Bob Bob is balling that's just gonna
hit yes ha the other yes yeah yes Bob
yes I'm gonna go like this the ground
just in case go I just want to see if
it'll pick someone off as they're about
to win me in the ass
oh we will go god whoa
Wow look at this garbage way this was a
mistake
come on makes it easy yeah I won't do
that I won't do that because he took his
time we were all being stupid
man how dare I win all right wait I like
this it's like oh we actually tried to
not saw we got to go through the door I
did crickets like that there we go I
guess account Wade thank you you're so
good oh well you bounced up and hit
that spike wall that's a diner I
look Jack up points ma
the system possible hahahaha this dude
does this - Oh mark you see dick
what did i do i'm a shmatte it's
slightly more difficult well slightly
are you jack tragedy things that are
gonna help I'm trying to I'm gonna dick
someone over oh wow that's what we need
more up here
yeah I'm not gonna make it that much
harder Oh Jack no yes Chuck yes Jack yes
yes yes yes girl oh god the oh that
is every time you stop oh it's
impossible
oh god possible know you guys can Blum
stuff you don't have to keep adding it's
not my fault
I want to make this pass happiness we're
not eggs right I'm gonna make this tak
Pappas here we go here we go all right
I'll get rid of this this piece of
this is useless then I added a whole
other platform good for you whatever
go away puck douchebag what god
oh my jumped oh wait ha ha
Jackie you can do it can't you
I can't good at games I go through the
door you gotta go through the door jack
nice plus those men I have no idea we're
gonna assume that wasn't pure luck and
everything's gonna be okay that was that
was beautiful man ah probably Bob I'm
still thinking I'm always Bob I do it he
goes incognito
I know marks little square of our boy
are there thank you it's my favorites
you can't land on it Oh God
huh damn it
goodbye I just freaked the out man
it makes me lose my every time
weightless is I just died
two turns okay put some honey there
I didn't know what else to do all right
hide mine you always wait till last but
Bob Bob ah cheat do it Bob
no definitely not I was never losing do
it Bob maybe honey I put honey oh god
damn it
oh harsh
so I don't know how anyone can
win this now no it's possible
it's definitely possible it's just
annoying hey I've got something I've got
something that will definitely help I
don't even know what this plane it
doesn't do anything you need to know
that no it does do so if you puts that
where there's two of them not unless
someone deleted the other one yeah it's
gone I delete okay then yeah we'll do -
there's to be two of them Oh one okay
all right Bobby see more then nobody
gets a choice ha ha ha ha ha we'll see
you won't we it's it - easy there yeah
what if we you get to go right what if
we get to go on - up here just sure ok
all right
oh hey has a chance
Oh No hahaha come on sham permit I
thought its market I just Oh Jack that's
so stupid you get ahead of me because
you got the bonus like come back points
what a load on cavort God whatever ass
the keyboard all right there's one there
we go
oh man whatever alright let's
do it navigate the map hmm get up to the
level you're suck dicks Oh what do we do
oh the button triggers the elevator and
this last will kill you
what elevates the elevator this black
thing appears the elevator mode okay
let's just go ahead and crush people's
dreams right off the bat
let's do it do it
Hey Oh pretty easy the elevators gonna
be an easy oh wait we have to take the
elevator now no you don't have to but
it's gonna be easy fine by taking off I
could crush people's dreams to do it Bob
just crush the key question restraints
yes yeah okay I think I think this will
do what I wanted to do I don't I don't
know about that
come here elevator
oh god no Jesus oh so close you're gonna
oh wait oh god he's not sorry I knew
that was gonna happen and I still let it
right out I'm not sure I'll use a bomb
to destroy it I will use a bomb to
destroy it make it be in to be a dick be
a dirac a dad oh you think adopting oh
nothing
okay let her look sure let's have a
party
no what's this with the under midgut I
really thought I had it ready Bob
all right y'all what did you do jump
jacks the only one on the board - well
you keyboards Opie
dick dick barely dick now Americ now I'm
in bad mood please so grumpy dad
mad cuz bad maybe something Oh Bob
Bob think about what you sow oh how much
room do we need to get out there would
be the worst possible location you can
put it like how about this oh we long
through there that's that that's not I
think it's Betty something better than
that
I like I like whoever put this here I've
got thoughts I've got a little do we
have to duck beneath that hockey thing
while we're waiting
jump probably you know yeah you can't
took it Bob
oh god Bob my valium dead all right all
right good luck oh oh I
can't fit my dead body
it keeps hitting me involved oh he saved
you okay okay
so happy I was right now oh god mom ha
ha why is Jack that's Jack Jack's trying
to be a dick
Yeah right listen I'm gonna try to make
another avenue for us to go here
Jack Jack I hate you guys okay go ahead
do it jack
do it ah give it a bit more interesting
all right you know what I'm just gonna
make this part dad what's the other saw
on the elevator
hi jack you a hockey puck no thanks
for calling the elevator
oh god damn it I made my god that is too
high to go sniff my butthole okay okay
hahaha I think you can jump on the roof
Oh
which is like oh the booth here we
go
Oh God what the happen why did you
not die Kiki well yeah we're all just
gonna casually wait it's literally
impossible all right we can do this jack
we could do this you guys know you can
write on the roof of the elevator too
right
I know but the axis are always covering
the roof now from the bow
you guys want to finish this level
you later
you oh my god have fun get up the
elevator
let's that might be easy now thank you
Bob god I think you guys get sucked into
the black hole
I didn't yeah I got shot with an arrow
nice it got to the point where the black
hole was keeping me from jumping so I
couldn't go Bob what is Bob Bob Bob Bob
come on oh there's already an arrow
thing over there oh yeah total overkill
all right next round I'm just gonna
start blowing up this cuz god damn
yeah this is a four awful human being I
need only one with anything on a
leaderboard right now oh yeah because of
look I'm just gonna wait down here thank
you I'll be okay no you won't wait you
did this to yourself
yeah
you buddy good jumping are ya good there
you go hi Bob show us what you got Bob
oh you're dead